[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à strasbourg au
parlement européen ravi de vous
retrouver pour 30 minutes de décryptage
d'actualité européenne dans la seconde
partie de cette émission focus sur le
couple franco allemand
le lendemain de son accession à la
présidence de la république
emmanuel macron s'est rendu à berlin
chez la chancelière angela merkel
mais qu'en est il de ce couple
franco-allemand sur le terrain reportage
entre strasbourg et kehl à la frontière
franco allemande mais d'abord
l'actualité
theresa may a perdu son pari après avoir
convoqué des législatives anticipées
pour renforcer son camp et mieux
négocier le bric site elle a finalement
perdu sa majorité absolue
un an après la décision du royaume uni
de sortir de l'union européenne la
première ministre britannique est plus
que jamais affaibli dans ces
négociations qui s'annoncent rudes et
qui n'en finissent plus d'être retardée
on écoute ce gouvernement guidera notre
pays dans les discussions cruciales sur
le break site qui commenceront dans dix
jours et répondra au souhait des
britanniques en menant à bien la sortie
de l'union européenne alors s'il ya un
message à retenir des résultats de ce
soir c'est celui ci
la première ministre a appelé à la tenue
de ces élections car elle voulait un
mandat et bien son mandat
c'est qu'elle a perdu des sièges
conservateurs perdu des voix perdues le
soutien et la confiance j'aurais pensé
que c'était assez pour qu'elle parte il
reste la place un gouvernement vraiment
représentatif du peuple et du pays
alors pour en discuter justement je
reçois guy verhofstadt bonjour guy
verhofstadt vous êtes ancien premier
ministre belge vous êtes à la tête du
groupe libéral démocrate au sein de ce
parlement et vous êtes le coordinateur
des travaux de ce parlement pour le
break cite justement vous le disiez vous
même dans un tweet il y a quelques jours
à la suite donc de ces élections
britanniques que theresa may avait fait
un but contre son camp est ce à dire guy
verhofstadt qu'elle n'a plus sa place à
la tête du gouvernement britannique
c'est pas à nous de décider de cela aux
britanniques et aux partis politiques en
au royaume-uni d'en décider mais ce qui
pour nous important je crois est tout à
fait capital c'est que maintenant il ya
un gouvernement en place
ouais équiperont paix si je n'ai pas
affaibli pour mener des négociations est
possible mais ça c'est leur
responsabilité ce qui est important
c'est qui maintenant ils donnent leur
position
est-ce-qu'il qu'on ne connaît toujours
pas non parce que ils ont envoyé une
lettre de notification 9 mars qui
contenait quand même vu ce qu'on appelle
en anglais arabe l'ex et on a livré dur
extérieur ou sortir d'une marché unique
sortir de l'union et erp etc etc tandis
que naturellement l'électorat
britannique a voté différemment c'est à
dire que l'électorat britannique en fait
à a balayé ce à back seat ont dit qu'il
y aurait des négociations entre la ligne
des conservateurs plutôt pour un soft
break site avec les libéraux démocrates
est ce que ça vous y croyez que cette
ligne puisse être influés c'est
maintenant au gouvernement britannique
tout d'abord d'avoir une majorité parce
que ça c'est pas encore clair et
deuxièmement ton décidé
est-ce qu'il faut continuer de all
blacks cet os que par contre on ouvre le
jeu on dit voilà il ya encore des
coopérations possibles avec l'union
européenne ça doit être en fait
clarifier très vite pourquoi parce que
l'incertitude auprès des gens et de nord
est et de nos entreprises est énorme
vous voyez que par exemple le premier
trimestre de cette année la croissance
économique grande-bretagne déverser
jusqu'à 0,2 pour cent c'est presque donc
il n'y a plus aucune croissance
économique maintenant en grande bretagne
on s'est arrêté en grande-bretagne passe
yann cette incertitude risque aussi pour
la zone euro derrière pour le reste du
continent quand on voit à quel point
l'économie britannique est impacté de
cette attente de celles naturellement
naturellement même si c'est aussi une
opportunité
justement pour clarifier réformer la
zone euro la gouvernance de la zone euro
parce qu'il faut pas simplement discuter
de la sortie de la grande bretagne il
faut au même moment en fait réformer
l'union européenne faire de sorte qu'on
ait en tornade est des instruments réels
justement pour pour combattre des crises
économiques qui sont dus à par exemple
un vrai clip
alors on a vu en plusieurs truites à la
suite de tous à michel barnier entre
autres qui dit que les négociations en
fait doivent démarrer quand les la
grande bretagne sera prête parce que le
les positions en fait de l'union
européenne sont claires donald de tous
sur la même ligne
on ne sait pas en fait quand les
discussions vont pouvoir démarrer tout
ce qu'on sait c'est que elles vont se
terminer et que le risque derrière ce
qu'il n'y ait un audit il vous même
longueur et doit se terminer le 20 le 29
mars 2019 une approbation par ce
parlement européen qui ne sera pas
facile alors est ce que vous seriez prêt
par exemple si on voit que la situation
politique est toujours aussi chaotique
en grande-bretagne à repousser cette
date du 29 mars
je pense qu'il n'y a aucune raison pour
reposer ses sept ces dates parce que ça
donnerait alors la possibilité de
d'entrer dans des tractations de nouveau
dans des difficultés qu'ils mais là on
parle quand même aussi par exemple des
recettes de droits acquis des citoyens
une vie pour garantir ces droits il faut
repousser un petit peu cette deadline ça
c'est pas nécessaire la position de
l'union européenne est très claire sur
les droits des citoyens tant les
citoyens britanniques qui vivent chez
nous que les citoyens européens qui
vivent là bas au royaume uni ce que nous
voulons c'est garder les droits qu'ils
ont maintenant et ne pas commencer à
traiter les ressortissants européens qui
vivent au royaume uni comme des pays
10 qui viennent au bout des gens qui
viennent des citoyens qui viennent
d'autres pays dans le monde et donc là
on est très clair et on veut donner les
mêmes droits
ça c'est aussi très clair aux
britanniques qui vivent en europe
là il nous faut réciprocité et pour nous
c'est une priorité c'est la première
chose à négocier
et tout ça on ne doit pas arrêter
maintenant la négociation ou ne pas les
commencer ou prendre plus de temps mais
vous comprenez que si en fait au 29 mars
il ya no deal est donc un saut dans le
vide parce que il n'y aura pas de
contrat qui ce qui aura été négocié
c'est un saut dans le vide
aussi pour ces spéciales mais en tout
cas nous voulons que déjà en septembre
octobre donc il faut pas attendre de
2019 il y à un accord sur les droits des
citoyens le droit des citoyens européens
vivent là bas et les droits des citoyens
qui pourrait passer parfois par exemple
est-ce qu'on pourrait offrir une
citoyenneté de manière plus facile
c'est une autre question qui est lié à
ça il ya beaucoup de moi je reçois des
pétitions je reçois des lettres des
milliers de lettres de citoyens
britanniques qui disent nous on veut on
ne veut pas perdre nos dossiers royal
était européenne et n'a pas d'accord
qu'on le perde et donc moi je suis
ouvert à voir quels sont les droits qui
sont liés ou citoyenneté européenne
qu'on peut encore donner aux
britanniques qui le demandent
ciao bella et emmanuel macron ont
déclaré que la porte restait ouverte aux
britanniques s'il voulait revenir sur le
break site est ce que vous êtes sur
cette même île oui je suis d'accord avec
avec eux mais naturellement ce sera
peut-être pas la même porte la porte
ouverte oui mais ce ne sera pas la même
porte parce que entre temps on va que
même réformer l'union européenne ce sera
une union européenne beaucoup plus
simples avec moins de complexité avec
aussi moins d'exceptions il faut en
finir avec une union européenne comme
c'est le cas avec la grande bretagne
d'aujourd'hui où ce sont les pays qui
choisissent leur coopération
il ya des pays qui sont dans schengen
d'autres pays ne sont pas d'enseigner à
des pays qui sont dans leurs eaux
d'autres pays ne sont pas dans l'euro il
ya des pays qui participent au brevet
européen et d'autres pays qu'ils
participent pas ça ne va plus il faut
une union européenne qui est une vraie
union donc la porte ouverte
mais c'est sarah la porte vers une autre
union que l'union d'aujourd'hui dans
laquelle chaque pays d'abord la grande
bretagne choisissent elle même ses
propres politiques
ça sera fini dans l'avenir dit mme
charone le chef du parti libéral
démocrate a fait quelques déclarations
concernant la décision de theresa may de
discuter avec le pud le parti unioniste
donc irlandais on écoute comme david
cameron avant tel notre première
ministre a voulu jouer avec le feu
mettant en danger l'avenir de notre pays
par arrogance et vanité et maintenant
elle est affaiblie elle fait appel à sa
droite pour former sa propre coalition
no ko
vivalis est une coalition de chaos
l'alliance de theresa may des
conservateurs avec le pud irlandais oui
c'est en tout cas une une
une majorité qui qui qui sera instable
parce qu'on sait très bien on a quand
même sur le continent julie rey
l'expérience de gouvernement de
coalition et on sait que dans des
gouvernements de coalition des
gouvernements minoritaires qu'ils sont
soutenus par d'autres partis dans dans
le parlement c'est toujours un élément
d'instabilité veut c'est pour ça que moi
j'espère mais c'est une
c'est un souhait pas plus que ça c'est
pas une directive en vers l'est les
britanniques que dans leur
positionnement
le gouvernement britannique a essayé de
trouver un compromis entre les grands
partis et britanniques parce que en fait
la sortie de la grande-bretagne de
l'union européenne c'est pas la sortie
du parti conservateur douanes
européennes
c'est là qu'ont pris avec les
libéraux-démocrates par exemple aulas
c'est pas moi de donner des directives
avec qui doit il est clair quand même
que une majorité des gens dans ces
élections n'ont pas voté pour une ligne
dure venant de prague site
et ça c'est quand même une toute autre
signal d'une tout autre message que les
mets theresa may pour l'instant n'a pas
entendu semble-t-il est ce qu'il ya un
risque en fait dans cette union
justement dans cette coalition avec le
pud de voir les accords de paix irna
des fracassé c'est pour ça que le
parlement européen va justement
contrôler ça là pour nous la priorité
c'est la paix en irlande du nord
le fait qu'il n'y a pas de frontières
qui est rétabli entre la république
irlandaise d'une part et les relents du
nord et troisièmement naturellement les
les accords de paix qui doivent être
respectées il a bon on peut avoir des
doutes parce qu'ici naturellement le
gouvernement britannique fait un accord
avec le dmp donc c'est les unionistes
les protestants du nord il ya toute
cette partie de la population qui est la
partie catholique qui est effrayée des
cela est donc c'est pour cette raison là
une des grandes priorités du parlement
ce sera de contrôler et de sauvegarder
cela fera bon de commande y pas de
frontières dure entre l'irlande du nord
et la république et respect à ce en
fonction de tous les deux tout les
dispositions de l'accord de paix
dernière question vous avez j'imagine
suivi les premiers pas des manuels
macron sur la scène européenne et sur la
scène internationale
il est question d'une relance du couple
franco-allemand de revoir la zone euro
diriez vous que le couple anglais la
merkel et emmanuel macron et le beaucoup
plus pour réformer l'europe ou
faudrait-il pour un alignement de
planètes que ce soit martin schulz qui
prennent la tête a donné des consignes
de prudence ou des pronostics en
allemagne mais il est clair
naturellement avec emmanuel macron les
choses vont changer parce que moi j'ai
connu quand même dans le passé la france
était toujours très actif au niveau
européen mais c'était un peu une
approche intergouvernementale à dire ce
soit très fédéraliste emmanuel macron
c'est tout à fait différent quand je les
ai rencontrés il ya un an plus ou mois
il m'a raconté cette proposition il m'a
parlé de ses propositions pour réformer
l'union européenne et c'est ce sont deux
proposition à laquelle moi comme
fédéraliste européen
je peux adhérer à 200% bon merci
beaucoup
guy verhofstadt d'avoir répondu à nos
questions nous on continue
justement on a voulu voir en quoi
consistait ce couple franco-allemand sur
le terrain nous sommes ici à strasbourg
à quelques minutes de la frontière
franco-allemande et donc de quel
reportage de sagna de sheer à 38
[Musique]
je m'appelle robert corsini je suis
conducteur de tram à la cts je vais
prendre en service sur la ligne d de
quel bahnof vers strasbourg
[Musique]
chaque jour des milliers de personnes
passent la frontière qui sépare la
france et l'allemagne et depuis un mois
et demi
elles peuvent désormais le faire en
tramway presque sans s'en rendre compte
aucun panneau n'indique qu'on change de
pays tiers pour prolonger la ligne du
tram les strasbourgeois jusqu'à kehl en
allemagne
il a fallu trois ans de travaux et un
investissement de 100 millions d'euros
partagés dans les deux pays
aujourd'hui vous faire cette ligne
franco allemande par dessus le rhin
c'est une manière de construire l'europe
du quotidien mais c'est une manière
d'envoyer un message fort au moment où
les frontières se ferment en europe
alors moment où les murs et riche dans
le monde
nous ici nous dépassons nous faisons de
la coopération franco allemande et
européenne
mais au delà du symbole
les citoyens français passe t-il
simplement la frontière pour acheter les
cosmétiques et du cabba moins cher en
allemagne
ont-ils vraiment le sentiment de
partager une identité et un destin
commun au next matata eu la glace mariée
à un allemand mag avis vient tout juste
de s'installer à kehl où vivent trois
mille français pour faciliter les
démarches administratives des
transfrontaliers la région de l'ortenau
et la métropole strasbourgeoise se sont
regroupés dans un territoire pilote
appelé eurodistrict maison quotidien
être français et vivre en allemagne
reste compliqué c'est des tracasseries
pour chaque chose
pères amis pour refaire le permis en
fermière est français il a fallu que je
le fasse ici dans les démarches à
allemande voilà c'est c'est des
histoires pour la sécurité sociale pour
les remboursements de frais de soins
c'est des tracasseries pour les impôts
c'est des choses qui est beaucoup
d'administrations à la fois du côté
français et côté allemand ne comprennent
pas malgré leurs efforts les élus le
cours sur souvent au mur des
administrations nationales même pour les
choses les plus simples jusqu'en 2015
il existait par exemple un marathon
transfrontalier
mais pour des questions de certificat
médical c'est désormais une course
franco française
les allemands renonça à courir et du
coup depuis 2005 cette manifestation n'a
plus lieu en fait un 20 km en reste d'un
seul côté du rhin savent ça c'est une
catastrophe pour ce territoire c'est une
catastrophe pour cette intégration se
coupler pour son prolongement au delà
peut-être deux
de l'idée généreuse d'après guerre qui
était de faire la paix on
on monte plus la marche là on est coiffé
un certain niveau intermédiaire michel
hamy vite en france mais chaque jour il
traverse la frontière
parfaitement bilingue il dirige depuis
plus de 20 ans naciri bsw basée à
finnair
pour porter l'acier aux fusions la
température du four doit monter quatre
mille degrés des conditions de travail
pénibles mais les salaires sont
attractifs à bsw un ouvrier gagne en
moyenne 3400 euros net par mois
pourtant michel hamy a bien du mal à
recruter avec une natalité en baisse
l'allemagne manque de main d'oeuvre et
les candidats français ne se bousculent
pas vraiment au portillon 46000 alsacien
travail tu en allemagne c'est 20 % de
moins que dans les années 90 abs vous
l'avez emploi de 850 personnes
parmi ces 850 personnes il y a
aujourd'hui 60 frontaliers c'est à dire
des français qui habitent en france et
qui travaille chez nous et c'est 60
étaient 120 il y a deux décennies nous
vous êtes dirigeant français en
allemagne vous essayé d'embaucher des
des français quand cela est possible et
c'est de moins en moins possible parce
que justement l'alsacien parle de moins
en moins l'allemand avec un taux de
chômage de 10% à strasbourg contre 4 %
outre-rhin le travail transfrontalier
pourrait fournir un emploi a beaucoup
d'alsaciens mais en france seuls 15% des
élèves du secondaire étudient l'allemand
soit 8% de moins qu'il ya 20 ans
même à quelques kilomètres de
l'allemagne on a beau franchir la
frontière tous les jours la barrière de
la langue
elle ne pas encore tombé
[Musique]
et voilà donc pour ce reportage de samia
de chira lors quelle place pour le
couple franco allemand est comment faire
tomber ces barrières pour en débattre je
reçois mes invités jo leinen bonjour
vous êtes député socialiste allemand et
donc vous êtes élu de la sarre ici au
parlement européen bienvenue à vous en
face de vous philippe juvin vous vous
êtes député français et vous êtes élu
donc à paris en ile de france et vous
êtes membre du groupe ppe donc les
républicains jeu messieurs une chose est
ce que quand vous voyez ce reportage
ce couple franco-allemand qu'on a essayé
de mettre en oeuvre qu'on pousse encore
aujourd'hui on le voit dans la
présidence d' emmanuel macron qui
s'installe cette volonté de relancer ce
couple est ce que sur le terrain on
n'est pas en train petit à petit de voir
qu'ils s'effiloche et que malgré tout en
fait cette distance elle est de plus en
plus importante jo leinen
non le couple franco-allemand c'est le
coeur de l'idée européenne si ce moteur
marche l'europe marche mais on voit bien
que sur le terrain il y a de moins en
moins de gens qui parlent allemand y
compris en allemagne de moins en moins
de gens parlent le français donc qu'est
ce que ça veut dire le couple franco
allemand s'est juste entre des
institutions entre des états si sur le
terrain ça ne se fait pas qu'est ce que
ça signifie qu'on peut pas faire
l'europe sont les citoyens les
institutions ne suffisent pas et pour
cela c'est tellement important que dans
le système d'éducation en france comme
chez nous la langue du voisin et a pris
et pas seulement l'anglais l'espagnol
il ya quelques efforts chez moi en sarre
on a une frankreich pratique une
stratégie français se disant on a créé
une génération elysées c'est à dire de
2013 tous les jeunes qui sont nés
apprennent le français dans le dans la
maternelle dans la maternelle okinda
garde jusqu'à l'université et j'ai vu
que dans le district et la moselle
ils ont créé une dodge ram stratégie
stratégie allemande des dix ans de faire
la même chose et c'est bien vous êtes
d'accord philippe juvin quand on voit à
quel point
l'apprentissage des langues en fait des
deux côtés de la frontière s'est délité
le couple franco-allemand finalement
c'est entre les institutions seulement
alors en fait comme disait pierre dac
tout est dans tout et réciproquement
c'est à dire que si ça ne marche pas sur
le terrain ou marche moins bien c'est
que là haut
la france d'en haut l'allemagne bat o ne
collaborent pas suffisamment comme elles
ont pu faire dans le passé et on le
voyait bien l'entrée partage non donc il
me semble que il ya une période assez
propice à la relance de cette
coopération franco-allemande au delà du
romantisme d'une relation qui est née
c'est ce qui est nécessaire aussi parce
que nous avons des références
culturelles communes
elle devient nécessaire plus qu' il ya
cinq ans il ya dix ans pour des raisons
politiques
lise l'isolationnisme américain les
britanniques qui sortent de l'union on
voit très bien que et la france et
l'allemagne ont des intérêts à retrouver
un couple fort les allemands parce que
même s'ils sont très puissant
aujourd'hui le l'allemagne est une est
un pays prospère avec d'excellents
résultats économiques une stabilité
économique l'allemagne à une stabilité
politique et une sa fille stabilité
politique l'allemagne souffre très
clairement d'un certain isolement
surtout que la grande bretagne est
l'allié naturel et les états unis
semblent un peu s'éloigner
la france elle a aussi cette
préoccupation est donc je pense qu'il
faut que là-haut les nos dirigeants
prennent conscience de la nécessité de
rebâtir des fondamentaux c'est quoi les
fondamentaux premièrement en france il
faut qu'on soit de nouveau vertueux
économiquement parce que sinon ce ne
sont que des paroles et en allemagne
il est probable qu'il faut que de
nouveaux l'allemagne apprennent à ne
plus décider seul je pense à toutes les
décisions sur le climat sur l'énergie
sur l'immigration il ya des efforts
concrets affaires peuvent donc pourquoi
ça passe encore par le couple
franco-allemand philippe juzan cette
relance d'abord 8 de l'italie quid de
l'espagne à d'autres puissances
régionales dont on a besoin
non bien entendu la pologne on voit très
bien que l'europe ce n'est pas que la
france et l'allemagne
cependant pour des raisons
démographiques pour des raisons
industrielles et économiques
on voit très bien que le couple franco
allemand est évidemment
celui qui peut donner une installation
particulière une impulsion d'impulsion a
écrasé l'italie c'est un pays fondateurs
de l'europe mais lorsqu'on voit la
politique en italie ils ont eu 55
gouvernement de plus de là alors c'est
pas très stable oui autrement l'italie
sera quelqu'un dans le triangle et vous
avez bien dit que la pologne ne faut pas
oublier les nouveaux venus dans l'union
européenne sur tout le monde est en pays
de la pologne d'aider des pays qui
posent problème un pardon jo leinen la
pologne sur les questions de valeurs de
droits de l'homme
de mes raisons mais sur la démo la
hongrie sont peut pas faire sans sa pipe
et européens sur la dénoncer sur
l'énergie ils sentent le danger dans
leur dos de la russie de poutine
alors là ils sont très européen dans
d'autres dossiers notamment sur les
migrations et on arrive bon dernière
question john heinen quand vous voyez
les signaux qu emmanuel macron a envoyé
à berlin en nommant un conseiller
diplomatique qui est ancien ambassadeur
en nommant premier ministre qui est
germanophone bruno le maire qui est
également germanophone donc à bercy
sylvie goulard que l'on connaît bien ici
au parlement européen c'est des signaux
qu'on perçoit comme en allemagne mais ça
aide énormément le connaître l'autre
pays des connaître aussi la langue ça
ouvre les portes et c'est probablement
le gouvernement le plus germanophone
disons qu'il ait des personnes qui
connaissent l'allemagne et et j'espère
qu'à berlin aussi en a assez des gens
qui connaissent la france est seulement
de se connaître on peut ouvrir les
coeurs les esprits on peut faire des
choses vous aurez noté vous portez
j'imagine la candidature de martin
schultz qui connaît il allemagne et la
france allait mal merci messieurs
d'avoir des battues de nous avoir
éclairé sur cette question du couple
franco-allemand tout de suite c'est
l'heure du checkpoint de thomas mignon
cette semaine notre charte au mas s'est
intéressé à une déclaration de la france
insoumise sur l'harmonisation salariale
le checkpoint s'est tout de suite
[Musique]
l'harmonisation sociale en europe
c'est l'un des combats de la france
insoumise de jean-luc mélenchon à
l'occasion des élections législatives en
france le parti a créé un site web pour
analyser le programme d' emmanuel macron
en réaction à l'une des mesures prévues
par le président français on peut y lire
les traités européens interdisent
l'harmonisation salariale alors tout
d'abord quelles sont les écarts
salariaux entre et amant d'un pays à
l'autre le salaire horaire médian passe
du simple au double voire au décuple
quand un employé bulgare gagne 1 euros
67 de leur son homologue danois touchera
plus de 25 euros
la belgique est cinquième avec un
salaire horaire médian à 17 euros tandis
que la france pointe à la 9e place avec
un peu moins de 15 euros
les disparités sont donc bien là mais
l'union européenne empêche tel par ses
traités d'harmoniser l'ensemble les
traités définissent les actions que
d'entreprendre l'union et en matière de
rémunérations
la recommandation pour un socle européen
des droits sociaux résume l'union
encourage la coopération entre les états
pour l'emploi et on peut encore lire ce
faisant elle respecte pleinement les
compétences des états membres en la
matière le tout est à dos et d'une
mention les dispositions dudit article
ne s'applique pas aux rémunérations
l'union européenne a tout simplement pas
reçu des états membres le pouvoir
d'intervenir ou de légiférer en la
matière
mais cela ne signifie pas qu'elle
interdit une quelconque harmonisation la
commission européenne nous dit on n'en a
d'ailleurs pas la prétention
le coût de la vie est différent dans
chaque état harmoniser les salaires
n'est donc pas possible
et ajoute la commission nous
privilégions donc une approche qui vise
à élever le niveau de vie de l'ensemble
des états membres
bref quand la france a soumises assure
que les traités européens interdisent
l'harmonisation salariale c'est plutôt
faux et voilà c'est faux et c'est le
checkpoint de thomas mignon c'est la fin
de cette émission mais pas de panique la
semaine prochaine ce sera à mettre à
zéro commandes depuis bruxelles pour la
dernière de la saison
merci à aurélie d'afas et salomé et rose
rôle douglas qui m'aident à
régulièrement préparer cette émission
merci aux équipes techniques ici au
parlement européen pascal aux manettes
script caméraman maquilleuse ingénieur
du son booking sans qui rien ne serait
possible merci à vous de votre fidélité
on se retrouve
à la rentrée pour continuer à décrypter
cette très riche actualité européenne
très bel été à tous ciao
[Musique]